>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Speaker 2: Welcome to
the Library of Congress
and the Young Readers Center.
Has anyone been here before?
Great. Look at that.
We thank you for coming and
we hope you will come back
to this very special afternoon
with the European Union
Kids Euro Festival.
The European Union is made
up of countries very far
away across the big ocean.
There are 28 countries that have
come together to bring artists
and entertainers to come to
America and introduce children
from the D.C. area about their
country and what they do.
But we have a very special guest
today because we have an ambassador
from Slovenia which is a country
about the size of New Jersey.
And ask your teachers
to get more information.
And the country, if you
could look at the map --
The brown part up there that says
Slovenia, it looks like a chicken.
Can you see that?
You can. So you can tell your family
when you go home that you learned
about a country very far away
that looks like a chicken.
Ambassador [inaudible] has
written a book for children called
"Little Mountain Fish Goes to Sea."
And he's written it and he has
it with him today and he's going
to read it to you and tell you
a little bit about himself.
Ambassador, thank you.
>> Bozo Cerar: Good
afternoon from myself as well.
Believe me, usually I read books
just for either my children
or my grandchildren, but
it has never happened
to read my stories
to such a huge crowd.
So I'm really pleased.
I'm really delighted.
First I will sit down like you.
Take the book.
And the book was written
for -- to my grandchildren,
Eric and Max [assumed spelling].
Both are your age.
I wrote it in my language, Slovenia
language, and the gentleman sitting
over there with that
white beard, you see him,
he translated it in to English.
So I will read it to you in English
so that you're able to understand.
What -- Are we ready?
Shall we start?
Okay. Let's do it.
Let's start it.
The name of the story is "Little
-- " The title of the story is,
"Little Mountain Fish Goes to Sea."
You know what the fish is.
Yeah. And you know what the sea is.
I hope. If not, I [inaudible].
So once upon a time there was a
little fish which lived with his mom
and dad in a crystal
clear pool in a creek high
up a mountain [inaudible].
Yes. The pool was surrounded by
majestic fruit trees and [inaudible]
and amid the roots of one of
the fruit trees the little fish
and his parents had a cozy home.
You see that home up there?
The little fish was very curious.
He constantly kept asking his mom
and dad about one thing or another.
And one day he began
asking what the world was
like beyond the nine pools,
beyond the nine creeks.
His parents didn't quite
know what to tell him
for they had spent all their
lives in their home creek
and they had been quite happy there.
However, the little fish had
heard from a very old fish
that beyond the nine pools and
beyond the nine creeks lay sea.
And the sea was a really large pool.
So large that one could not see
across from one shore to the other.
And so deep that one could
not see to its bottom.
How is this possible?
The little fish was wandering.
Even in spring when snow was
[inaudible] the mountains
or during summer rainstorms
when water in the creek rose
and grew a little cloudy,
both shores of his [inaudible]
and his bottom could fill the sea.
"I must go and see this
marvel," decided the little fish.
"I could do that best
during my vacation."
His mom and dad tried
to talk him out of it,
but nothing has changed his mind.
The little fish wanted to be
well prepared for his journey.
But the very old fish -- The
very old fish didn't know much
about the sea or the way to it.
He had been in the river and even in
a lake, but never as far as the sea.
Anyway, he did not like to
talk about what had happened
to him during his journey.
Obviously it wasn't pleasant.
But the very old fish heard another
old fish tell to the [inaudible]
that many years ago in a nearby
creek he met someone who had swum
from the sea to these
waters under the mountains.
He had clearly been just as
curious as the little mountain fish,
but since he lived in the
sea it was the mountains
that he was curious about.
The little fish got himself a
red traveling bag like this.
You see? And put it with some
food and a few useful things
that a fish might need
most on a journey.
He didn't forget to take along
a dictionary of fish languages
with this, a dictionary
of fish languages.
You see? Then the dictionary
of course of fish languages.
And a chart, a water map for fish.
And of course a camera.
Where is camera?
A camera is [inaudible]
camera with a [inaudible].
And because the old fish told
him that at sea the sun is very,
very hot, and glares terribly, so
he borrowed his aunt's straw hat.
See? And sunglasses.
Sunglasses.
These are ordinary glasses,
and these are sunglasses.
You see? So the fish was
well equipped for a journey.
[Inaudible] has used the hat,
them and the glasses once or twice
in the middle of summer
[inaudible] between two pools,
although there really was no
need for them in that place.
Early next morning he went.
Then he swam away.
He really did not even have to swim.
It was enough to just lean
on the red traveling bag
and the creek itself carried
them both downstream toward the
unknown world.
See? Just like this.
[ Laughter ]
Now on the banks of the creek
trees were passing by one
after another like in a movie.
And now and then he saw a
house or a solitary water mill.
He also noticed there were
cows and sheep grazing
and children playing
on the green meadow.
[Inaudible] yeah?
He waved to them with his tail,
this, and the children waved back.
So wave the fish back.
Good. Thank you.
Hardly believing what
they were seeing.
A fish on a red traveling bag?
You just don't see
such a thing every day.
All parents will again think
that we have made this all up.
The creek was joined
by other creeks.
There he ran in to a
group of [inaudible]
and small fish on their
way to a lake.
They just could not believe that the
little fish was headed so far away
to the sea and all along there
instead of narrow footbridges
across the creek there
are [inaudible] small
and then large road bridges.
Suddenly he found himself
in a river.
On this bank there were
even more fields filled
by hard working farmers.
There are more and more houses.
And they were bigger and taller.
And this was so different from
the neighborhood of his home pool
and everything so interesting out
of curiosity he stretched his neck
up out of the water and joyfully
wiggled his tail like a [inaudible].
With his camera he took
many beautiful pictures.
Many beautiful pictures.
But he was a little bit concerned
because the mountains he was used
to seeing up close were
getting smaller and smaller
and ever more lost in the haze.
Yet he did not lose his enthusiasm.
Traveling with his red traveling
bag was not only interesting,
but also pleasant.
He did not need to
swim even one fin.
The current carried him
downstream all by itself.
About the river flittered
countless little flies
and the little fish did not only --
needed only to open his mouth wide,
like this, and there was
a tasty lunch or dinner.
There was no need at all to
fear that he would lose his way.
Always all streams
led down to the sea.
But when the little fish woke
up next morning [inaudible]
but in the morning woke up.
Let's see what has happened.
His heart sank.
He was in altogether
new surroundings.
The water hardly moved.
He had to fully sway his
fins [inaudible] to keep
on moving with his traveling bag.
He could barely see
the banks of the river.
What trees grew, he did not know.
The water was murky and deep
and it also tasted different.
It was becoming ever more salty.
The fishes he met there looked
somehow -- somewhat different.
And were very difficult
to understand.
He was lucky to have brought along
the fish language dictionary.
So he just looked at the dictionary.
He was lucky to have
this book with him.
The river was slowly
flowing to the sea.
The old fish had been right.
All around, nothing but water.
And very deep, at that.
Also pretty warm.
Not too clean.
And, above all, salty
to make one sick.
Oh. Luckily his traveling bag
was somehow light in sea water.
The water was filled with fish.
Wait. Fish.
Big ones. Small ones.
Tiny ones.
Blue and red ones.
Even yellow ones.
Some pretty.
Some ugly.
Some very friendly, but
others you would just
as soon stay far away from.
Above all, the greatest sharks.
Yeah. Sharks.
And the sea was packed
with other creatures.
Other creatures like
stinging jellyfish,
colorful shellfish,
to playful dolphins.
In such crowds you have to be really
careful not to bump against someone.
But he busily kept taking
pictures with camera.
Yes. The surface of the
sea too was very crowded,
full of row boats,
sailboats, and ships.
These were large, larger
than whales,
larger than the largest fish.
They had been built by
human for various purposes.
They were carrying
all sorts of things,
and mostly they were very
friendly, but as he found later,
some of the ships were
also dangerous,
particularly the fishing boats as
those were made for catching fish.
[Inaudible] the shore
people too were swimming.
People never waded in to
their pool in the mountains
because the water was too cold.
When the wind began to blow large
waves rose from the sea such as
like many other things
[inaudible] the waves roared
and tossed the little fish every
which way and he felt very sick.
He had to watch out not to
be dashed against the rocks.
He held tightly to his
traveling bag, you know,
tightly to the bag
so not to lose it.
That would be a disaster.
All the pictures he was [inaudible]
but when the wind quieted down
and the sea became calm
the little fish wanted
to enjoy a little rest and sunshine.
After all, he was on vacation.
He put on his glasses.
Where are glasses?
Inside? You think so?
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Oh good. He put on
his glasses like this.
What else?
Let's see.
Donned his straw hat.
Yes. Like this.
And stretched out on his red
traveling bag which was now --
which now swayed lazily under
the hot sun on the blue sea.
This was a scene for a picture
postcard with a message,
"Greetings from a fish of the sea."
The sway and the hot sun
soon lulled him to sleep.
But he did not snooze for long.
He was awakened by the
screeching of seagulls.
Seagulls. What did they do to him?
The red traveling bag could
be seen from far away,
red colors seen from far away.
And when the seagulls saw
the little fish sunning
on it they just could
not believe it.
At first they argued
whether they saw it right.
Then they could not
quite agree which one
of them would get the traveling
bag and which one the little fish.
Just long enough for the
little fish to quickly plunge
in to the sea [inaudible] straw hat
set to sea was left to seagulls.
This is crazy.
Who can know his way around
this world in these waters?
Where you are not safe
either on the water or under?
The little fish was very scared.
But then a friendly crab invited him
and his traveling bag
in to his home.
That is under this rock.
Under this rock there was this home.
The crab also taught him about
all the other bad sides of life
in the sea, but also
about the good sides.
The little fish just realized that
the sea's not only interesting
and beautiful, but sometimes also
unfriendly and even dangerous.
In the end he decided that
the sea was not for him.
Maybe for a day or two since a
fish can see many interesting
and useful things, but he
would not want to live there.
Too hot. Too salty.
Too noisy.
Too crowded.
And for a little fish
definitely too dangerous.
He began to miss his folks,
his home pool, the clear,
cool mountain waters, the
reflection of the mountains in them,
the roots of his home's
[inaudible] trees.
He made up his mind to turn home.
He put some seashells
and other souvenirs
in his bag so that it was full.
He also took a picture with a
friendly crab in front of this rock.
He bid goodbye to his kind
host and under the power
of night swam toward the mouth of
the river and toward his mountains.
By sun up he was already in the
river flowing from his mountains.
His travel was hardly easy.
He got very tired pushing
his traveling bag,
especially in the opposite
stretch of the river.
But the nearness of
the high mountains
and of the green forests
was giving him new strength.
He was glad to see all the
[inaudible] bridges, the cows
and sheep, and children
that [inaudible].
This time too they
waved to each other.
So wave. Wave to the fish.
Yeah. A few more swishes
with his fins
and he would be back
in his home creek.
He would be telling his relatives
and friends about his sea adventures
and show them the pictures.
Now he understood much better
why his mom and dad loved
so much their little home amid
the roots of a mighty fir tree.
How right was the very
old fish, he thought?
It is beautiful everywhere, but it
is most beautiful in the home pool.
And [inaudible] the end.
Thank you.
Maybe you have any questions?
Yes? What's your name?
Yes. Go ahead.
>> Speaker 3: Why did the little
fish want to go out to the sea?
>> Bozo Cerar: Because
he was very curious
and the children usually
are very curious.
He wanted to see not just
his own, let's say, creek,
his own immediate surroundings.
He wanted to see what is on
the other side of the mountain
in the deep waters in the sea.
So that's why he decided to go.
Here?
>> Speaker 4: Why does
his head look so much
like a [inaudible] in that picture?
>> Bozo Cerar: Sorry.
I didn't get.
Why is -- Could you help me because
I really -- What was the question?
>> Speaker 4: Why does his head --
>> Speaker 5: Oh.
Why is his head big?
He said why his head is big?
>> Bozo Cerar: Enough.
For a small head fish,
everything is big.
Bag. Even sunglasses.
Hat. Everything is big because
they're the small fish like you.
Yes? Hello there.
Yes.
>> Speaker 6: Why the
snow is melting?
>> Bozo Cerar: Oh yes.
Very good question.
You know, snow falls in winter.
That is very cold.
But in spring and summer when the
temperature's high, as you know,
the snow, the ice, melts
away because it is warm.
It is hot.
Clarice [assumed spelling]?
>> Speaker 7: Why does
it get a tail?
>> Bozo Cerar: the fish?
Well, we have hands, legs.
Fish have fins and tails.
Yeah. Like any other animal.
Animals usually do have [inaudible].
Thomas [assumed spelling] yes.
Thomas, ask.
>> Speaker 8: You should
let him first.
>> Bozo Cerar: Who?
Go.
[ Inaudible ]
Fish is kind of what?
>> Speaker 9: Why is
the fish [inaudible]?
>> Bozo Cerar: Like a pig?
Do I understand you correctly?
Like a pig?
>> Speaker 10: Why is
the fish that color?
>> Bozo Cerar: Well, look.
The others who painted it thought
that it should be that way,
but you can, as we have
heard in your story,
fish can be blue, red, yellow.
So this one is --
>> Speaker 11: They
can be any color.
>> Bozo Cerar: Exactly.
Grey. Yes.
Of course.
I saw a lot of them grey.
Blue? Red?
Red as well.
Which? Green?
Green were some of them, but usually
the grass is green and the trees.
White. White.
The stones and sand are white.
Yes. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Ask a question.
Will somebody help him?
Okay. Who else?
You. Go ahead.
Go ahead.
>> Speaker 12: Why did the
fish [inaudible] the other side
of the mountains?
>> Bozo Cerar: Because
he was curious.
He wanted to know more
than parents told him.
He wanted to learn, like you.
He wanted to learn
as much as possible,
to be a clever fish,
really clever fish.
Clever what?
Yeah. Likewise.
>> Speaker 12: But
why was he curious?
>> Bozo Cerar: Well, I'm not sure
that I will really have
to answer that question.
What do you think?
Why the fish was curious?
Help me. Why the fish was curious?
>> Speaker 13: The fish was
curious because at the other side
of the ocean there were other
things and the fish can't see all
of them just in that little lake.
>> Bozo Cerar: Exactly.
Bravo. Bravo.
You have to go to see places you
would like to know what is there.
Yes.
>> Speaker 14: Why
the river was blue?
>> Speaker 15: Because
all rivers are blue.
>> Bozo Cerar: Some of them
-- majority of them are blue,
but some of them unfortunately
are polluted and are grey,
but usually if the water
is clear they are blue.
Black water?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. You're right,
because the Earth was black
and the Earth colored the water.
That [inaudible] all that as well.
Green? Why does [inaudible]
usually the grass is green
or the trees are green, but maybe
some waters are green as well.
Exactly. Yes.
>> Speaker 16: Why does the
mountains look like it's cold
and then the other part
looks like it's warm?
>> Bozo Cerar: Well, you're right.
The mountains look cold because
they are quite high covered
by ice and snow.
Yeah. And sometimes in summer
that ice and snow melts
and then the river, the creek,
become much, much larger.
And the water sometimes, as I said
in the story, is not that clear.
Who is going to ask
the last question?
>> Speaker 17: Who wants
to raise their hand?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Bozo Cerar: Okay.
>> Speaker 18: Why
did the [inaudible]?
>> Speaker 17: What did you ask him?
>> Bozo Cerar: Oh.
Well, the fish is -- The
fish swims like that.
Fishes don't have, let's
say, hands and legs.
They have fins and tails
and fish are that way.
That way. Or with [inaudible].
That's the way of swimming.
That's their way of swimming.
>> Speaker 17: Okay.
Let's give a hand for --
[ Applause ]
>> Bozo Cerar: Thank you.
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.